[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
a call for answers from those closest to
jonbenet ramsay what new information
could soon be released in the
decades-old cold case but first the
johnny depp versus amber her defamation
suit the op-ed
damaged
mr depp
created a cancel situation if you will
plus depp's talent manager explains how
amber heard's op-ed affected his career
impactful in a good or bad way
you know with respect to johnny it was
it was
catastrophic and later first-hand
testimony of a physical altercation out
of the corner of my eye i saw a
fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder we're live in
fairfax county virginia with day 12 of
testimony law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer the metoo
movement and cancel culture takes center
stage as week four kicks off in the
johnny depp versus amber her defamation
trial law and crime network's jesse
weber is live at the fairfax county
courthouse in virginia to break down the
impactful testimony jurors heard on
monday
yeah hey brian today was mostly an
interesting day focused on the impact
the 2018 washington post article had on
depp's career and reputation which is a
key element to his defamation claim but
the day first started off with more
evidence that amber heard was the one
who abused depp and we heard depp's
security guard travis mcgivern and he
testified that heard would call depp
horrible names and that when they would
fight depp would try to get away and not
physically fight back mcgivern even
explained how he failed to protect his
client from two attacks one when he says
heard chucked a red bull can hitting the
actor in the back and two when heard
allegedly punched depp which is
something that heard sort of
acknowledged in an audio recording that
was played earlier on in the trial but
mcgivern did acknowledge that depp
wasn't so innocent that he was verbally
abusive that he'd thrown herds clothing
all off their racks and from there we
heard from jack wiggum depp's talent
manager agent said that the star was
once making millions and then lost so
much because of the washington post
op-ed and we also saw the testimony of
an ip expert who just showed how depp's
likability really tarnished after these
allegations but to give you a sense of
this we also heard from richard marx in
an entertainment industry insider and he
explained the tremendous impact of the
washington post article
my general opinion is that the op-ed
damaged uh
uh mr depp
created a a cancel situation if you will
uh
harmed his reputation and his ability to
get work and yeah
hollywood industry the op-ed that didn't
mention mr deaf at all and didn't
mention any accusations that what
happened to her that's what caused mr
depp reputational all his reputational
harm that's what you're saying well i
don't agree that
this article was not about
mentioning that that's what i asked you
well does she have another husband who
abused her but they didn't talk about it
at all about mr depp's abuse objection
your honor he's tried to answer the
first question which was not exactly
what the second question was that he
reacted to audacity
yeah ask your question
the the op-ed article didn't mention any
specific abuse by mr deputy amber heard
correct
uh the only name is this is amber heard
telling her story that started in 2016
when she was domestically abused and
ignored
[Applause]
you know you would think that after
johnny depp left the stand the rest of
the testimony would be pretty boring not
the case at all all interesting and all
important for depp and heard brian
yeah jesse the information got really
interesting because it wasn't just
opinion there was also some statistical
evidence there especially especially
with q scores
that depp's career was hurt by herd's
op-ed do the numbers paint the picture
that depp's lawyers need in this case
kind of if you just look at the numbers
and his likability went down after the
2016 allegations and particularly after
2018 you'd say sure definitely looks
like amber heard's allegations hurt him
the problem is is under cross
examination you know it was pointed out
you don't know where you're getting this
information is it from humans is it from
bots the q scores seem to go up for any
reason which is a big problem and then
you see these spikes in the q scores
even before the article was published so
what are we really learning from these
stats exactly now jesse her's attorney's
main attack seems to be one of two
things uh one that dev's career was
already tanking and two that he
assaulted heard are these winning
arguments for this defamation claim
well it's their only arguments look if
he they can show that depp attacked her
physically that could be the end of the
case but in terms of the impact of the
article i mean there was so much
testimony about well what about the sun
lawsuit how much did that have negative
press for johnny depp he was also having
trouble making big blockbuster films
that were high quality is that one of
the reasons his career fell off he was
also receiving negative press for filing
a lawsuit against amber heard and then
of course the results from the uk trial
were not too favorable for johnny depp
so it still seems a bit unclear how much
impact the washington post article had
yeah terry real quickly what do you
think about this idea of this cancel
culture that johnny depp was a part of
it and a victim of it uh in this in this
allegation
yeah and that's interesting too because
it may they have to be very sensitive to
that language uh but again if she takes
the stand and she testifies and has a
very credible and believable story they
have to be very sensitive to that
subject matter and that's going to be
very tough for them but also here's a
case unlike any other where i have to
say johnny depp so far is painting a
very positive picture for himself yeah
it's a tight rope to walk and they seem
to be walking it very well jesse thank
you very much we'll be back with you
soon still ahead
we dig deeper into the contentious case
of x's johnny depp and amber hur jurors
hear a testimony from deaf's talent
agent how he says amber heard's op-ed
affected depp's future movie roles
[Music]
welcome back day 12 of johnny depp
versus amber heard saw a testimony from
dev's talent manager who told jurors how
amber heard's washington post op-ed
affected careers affected depp's career
how if at all was the op-ed different
from other articles you had read about
the johnny depp amber heard relationship
it you know it was a first person
account coming from
the victim
it's extremely impactful
impactful in a good or bad way
for on you know with respect to johnny
it was it was
catastrophic because it was coming from
you know a first person account it was
not from a journalist it was not from
someone observing it was from someone
saying this happened to me
wiggum told jurors debt received zero
offers for studio films after the
publication of the op-ed on cross
heard's attorneys highlighted the fact
that depp never had a contract for
pirate six
do you have an explanation why there is
not even a piece of paper not an email
not a text not a piece not a document
nothing that suggests that mr depp is
going to be in pirate six as jack
sparrow it would be fair to say that it
was consistent with a lot of the
conversations that i would have on
behalf of big stars where it was verbal
and there was an understanding of what
the what the deal was going to be that's
an easy yes or no have you seen a
document
technically i
i perhaps have because it connects to
all the other pirates films it's just a
modification of a new document so i i
have not seen
22.5 million written on a page you're
correct about that
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney julie rendellman and co-host
terry austin along with law and crimes
jesse weber julie it sounds like heard's
attorneys were trying to get out of this
witness that depp's career was already
on the decline when herd's op-ed came
out but did that come out very clearly
on cross
so look you know herd's defense
attorney's job is basically to go after
every witness that talks about this
whole issue of damages and the reason
they're doing that is johnny depp the
the hurdle they have is distinguishing
whether or not the damages happened just
because of the op-ed piece or because
all the other linear things that were
going on and how to break it up and and
that's a really hard thing for a jury to
be able to distinguish so look the
defense is doing their job in making it
clear we don't know if his dad if the
reputation was damaged because of this
op-ed or because all of the other things
that were going on by the way before the
op-ed piece ever happened and that's
johnny depp's responsibility not amber
herds the jury would decide at the end
whether or not they've been effective or
not yeah now terry did a wingham uh
wiggum sorry come off as credible in
connecting depp's loss to this article
or were herd's lawyer successful and
showing he's just looking out for his
own client
you know i think jack wiggum was very
credible he basically is trying to
establish whether or not disney was
ready willing and able to give depp
another position for that pirates
franchise and i think he did establish
that he talked about the fact that there
were many discussions about disney six
that they were going to pay him 22 and a
half million dollars he had dinners with
jerry bruckheimer and sean bailey at
disney the only thing that didn't exist
was that actual piece of paper but he
connected it to the original contract so
i think that that really did work yeah
now jesse uh reputation and damages seem
to be the focus for today's testimony
we've got experts in agents and and
graphs and everything like that but we
don't have anyone from disney confirming
these losses is that going to be a
detriment to johnny depp's case
it's a bit curious because i looked at
the witness list and i don't see any
disney executives testifying on his
behalf now i do think that amber hurt is
going to be calling a production
executive from walt disney pictures so
it makes me think that when you're
johnny depp and you have a choice about
who you're going to call and you choose
not to call a walt disney executive
that's partly because you're probably a
little nervous of what they might say
that's my initial take and why amber
heard is deciding to choose to call one
of those witnesses maybe that is
testimony that would benefit her side in
the sense that it was johnny depp to
blame for why his career took a nosedive
and not the washington post article yeah
and that could be a savvy way that a
lawyer gets around these allegations of
domestic abuse or assault and just
simply say hey look disney says this
wasn't the reason it was something else
it'd be interesting to see if they pivot
in that direction for this case jesse as
always thank you for the stellar
reporting uh we look forward to seeing
you again soon coming up on lawn crime
daily our coverage of the deaf herd
defamation suit continues with testimony
from johnny depp's security guard
things get heated when the witness
pushes back on cross-examination we take
you inside the virginia courthouse after
this
[Music]
welcome back our coverage of the johnny
depp amber heard defamation trial
continues now with testimony from one of
depp's security guards he describes an
instance when an argument between the
couple got physical and later clarified
what happened on cross-examination
i felt it was time to get mr depp out of
the situation so i stepped
in between miss heard and mr depp
telling
mr depp that we were that we were
leaving and that it wasn't up to him
anymore
um
at that point
out of the corner of my eye i saw a
fist and an arm come
[Music]
across my right shoulder and uh
i heard and saw a
closed
contact
mr depp and the left side of his face
and whose fist was that
that was miss herd's fist amber heard's
fist
well in fact you saw mr depp
push or shove whitney heard correct
absolutely not and it was only after mr
depp pushed whitney that amber stepped
forward and punched him in the face
isn't that right
that is not correct
terry hit by a red bull and punch in the
face how did you react when you heard
that amber allegedly did this to depp
you know i thought travis mcgovern was
very credible i thought that he told
what he saw that she threw a red bull
can that hit him in the back that she
punched him he denied that heard was you
know ever pushed or either sister was
pushed by depp and what i think is
particularly cruel is
she's doing all of this and he had just
literally had part of his finger chopped
off so i definitely think that it showed
that she can be extremely vicious that
she's throwing things and then punching
things and it also sheds a little bit of
light on that video we've been hearing
about where the two sisters are faking
or re-enacting a punch so i think it was
a really good job that mcgovern did here
as far as his testimony both on direct
and cross yeah julie there's a lot of
background as teres kind of point out
there but her defense attorneys seem to
have a completely different narrative of
how this punch occurred that hurt as you
heard there um punched up after pushing
her sister so did you think that
mcgivern sorry uh was lying for depp or
telling the truth
so i thought he did a great job and i
think you know the the the value of a
witness is how they do on direct and
cross and one of the things that allows
you to evaluate his credibility is the
fact that he doesn't make johnny depp
appear to be this angel he actually
describes him as the one who's quote
unquote rearranging amber heard's
clothing meaning that he's throwing all
the things out which which could be
arguably some type of act of violence
and he also puts himself in the
crosshairs by saying that johnny depp
was mad at him for his failure to act so
this gives him credibility for the jury
for them to understand he's not really
taking sides he's really just describing
what he saw happen as it happened i
think he was very effective obviously
the jury decides but but but i thought
this was definitely a win uh in terms of
johnny depp's side yeah the only one
pushback i would give on that is the
rearranging of someone's closet i think
it was a interesting choice of words he
wasn't rearranging he was destroying her
stuff but we'll see how the jury takes
that uh that point thank you both to
keep up with the gavital gavel coverage
of the johnny depp versus amber heard
trial make sure to follow our newest
podcast lawn crime sidebar listen in as
law and crimes top hosts recap the highs
and lows of the trial so far straight
from the fairfax county courthouse in
virginia subscribe on apple podcast or
online at lawncrime.com
when we come back the unsolved cold case
of jonbenet ramsay and a renewed push
from the six-year-old's father to solve
her murder and the boulder police's
response to a petition for independent
dna testing
[Music]
welcome back a texas man will spend the
rest of his life in prison after his
conviction and sentencing for the murder
of an elderly woman it took just 45
minutes for the jury to come to a
decision in the case of billy shamirmir
the kenyan immigrant was found guilty of
the smothering death of 81 year old
louis harris back in 2018. prosecutors
presented their case throughout the
week-long trial telling jurors shamirmir
followed harris home from a walmart
smothering her with her pillow and
stealing valuables to later sell online
investigators connected shamirmir with
harris's death after another woman was
attacked and survived police say they
found the keys to harris's home
wishimirmir along with a jewelry box
belonging to harris which had been
tossed in a dumpster harris isn't the
only alleged victim of chamirmir he's
been indicted on 18 counts of murder for
the deaths of other elderly women in the
dallas and plano area last week the
judge asked for the jury's verdict and a
few minutes later sentenced shamir muir
to life behind bars
[Music]
at this time uh having a jury of 12 that
have found you guilty of the offensive
capital murder it will be the assistance
and judgment of this court that you will
be taken by the sheriff's department is
safely held until you can be
released to those persons that protect
the department of criminal justice for
to serve a sentence of life without the
possibility
and in the unsolved case of jonbenet
ramsey the boulder colorado police
department releases a statement after
her father made a plea to further
analyze dna over the weekend john ramsey
the father of jonbenet went who was six
years old when she was found dead in
their family home spoke at crime con
2022 a weekend long conference in las
vegas for true crime fans ramsey is
asking for an independent investigation
and additional dna testing and the still
unsolved death of his daughter ramsay
wants the testing done by an independent
agency instead of the boulder police
department now the department is
responding to the push in a statement
sunday boulder's police chief said quote
we have a shared goal to bring justice
and hopefully some peace to jonbenet's
family and everyone who was impacted by
her loss he added the murder
investigation quote has always been and
will continue to be a priority for the
boulder police department on the morning
of december 26 1996 jonbenet's mother
reported a six-year-old missing to
police saying she discovered a ransom
note demanding a hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars jonbenet's body was
found later that day in the basement of
their home strangled to death and with a
blow to the head the girl's father is
now calling on colorado's governor to
use his power to intervene in the case
julie is there some sort of benefit or
harm to having an independent examiner
review the dna why wouldn't the boulder
police just say hey have about it
so think about it this way how bad would
the boulder police department look if
they released the reins of this
investigation to an outside agency and
the outside agency was able to determine
actually the person who committed this
crime i mean can you imagine the egg on
the face of the police department so in
a sense i think there's a level of
control they want to make sure that they
are the ones dictating what happens in
this investigation from the the vantage
point of the public the argument is well
if the police department hasn't been
able to figure out who committed this
heinous crime why don't we let fresh
eyes on it let other people take a look
and see if they can come up with a new
idea
a new investigation a new analysis in
regards to the dna and so it makes sense
to most people watching why not let
someone else take a look at it yes it's
not about who gets the egg on the face
or who gets the praise it's about who
finds this person's killer and was
putting an end to this mystery but we'll
see how it goes terry based on the
boulder police's response do you feel
they're doing everything they can do to
solve this case
actually i don't think they are doing
everything they can do they basically
have been looking into and investigating
this case since december of 1996 that's
26 years and yes it might be a
complicated case they said they've had
you know 21 000 tips they've gone
through letters and emails interviewed
like a thousand people but i think if
you can say let fresh eyes look at this
why aren't they doing that why are they
hesitating i think julie's right they
don't want to be embarrassed when in
fact something else comes up so they're
not doing enough well it seems
embarrassing now but let's hope we get
some answers here soon thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you